hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
what my reader is Jacky who had a
question about Twitter and in Jackie's
question is my problem is getting
legitimate followers I feel like I write
meaningful posts but people don't really
click on them
the followers I do have them people I've
followed were nice enough to follow me
back I don't want to use spammy software
to acquire more followers either I want
people to read my posts so Jackie a
couple of tips for you right now my
twitter feed is something around 45,000
people on growing so I want to give me
some advice and what I've done that
hopefully will help you as well the
first is you need to make your tweets
interesting and valuable right if
something's gonna be following you it's
gonna be valuable for them there's gonna
be a reason to want to follow you and
actually read what you're writing right
so it's kind of common sense you have to
be something that is tied to your brand
and is interesting and viable helps
their lives somehow the second thing I
would do is try to get them engaged and
try to ask questions so that they're not
just reading things but they can
actually be involved with some of the
posts that you're creating so some some
of the ones that I put up recently and
you try to tie it to your brand and
still make it fun so someone ones that I
put up are you know what's your favorite
food to snack on while you're working or
what did you do today to grow your
business and if something people can
answer in a couple of words but it gets
them involved so I'm not just posting
hey check out my latest blog post on XYZ
I'm asking them a question they can
answer it quickly and if they're
involved and they feel like they're
engaging in dialogue then the next time
I close something which might be a blog
post link they're more likely to want
click on it so you want to find easy
ways quick questions means a tie-in to
your brand and they can answer in a
couple words you don't want them writing
a huge essay and you can't on Twitter
the longer the the response and less
likely they're going to want
it's a quick you know want to word
answers that they can post and gets them
starting to interact with you and
engaging with you on Twitter and your
brand the last thing we do is try to set
up a schedule of tweets so that there's
variety coming and you're blind and all
different types of tweets going out
there so from my schedule something you
might be able to learn from usually in
the morning I'll post something that's a
famous entrepreneur quote and that ties
into my grand well so it could be
lessons from dawn Grover Winfrey or
whoever it is a quick inspirational
quote to help people start their day
then in the early afternoon I'll post
something related to my site so it could
be a blog post or another piece of
content I created that is promotional
you know helps me people click on it but
it's also value why I'm not saying go
buy whatever product I'm linking to
something that I might have created that
I think is strong value I and then in
the late afternoon I'll post something
that is more engaging so last time a
question like what did you do today to
grow your business and try to get people
to interact with that content so usually
that would be a staple of my tweeting
schedule I'll have at least those three
going out on a monday to friday type of
basis and then if i come across other
content that i really like it could be
an article that i've read that I want to
share that I didn't create and there's
no interest for me to want to promote it
aside from the fact that I think my
readers will like it and find value in
it then I'll tweet those up and I won't
just tweet the article title oh my own
two cents to it so you're you're making
yourself a little bit of an expert on
top of it so you're sharing something
you find interesting and out in your own
comment as well as people are looking
for that differentiating factor and they
were following your style and like with
you
have to say hopefully you can build up
that following so those I'll send out as
they come up as well and I use a program
called buffer app it's a free tool EU
FFP RPP and what it will do is allow you
to schedule your tweets so that you're
not tweeting everything all at once if
you read five articles once you've liked
them all you can have them send it out
over the course of the day or the next
two days or whoever it off and you want
and so you're not bombard and your
audience in too many comments or tweets
but over a period of time they'll get it
so hopefully that helps I'm curious to
see how it works out for you and if it
helps you grow your Twitter list because
I know it's really work for me if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up and it also love to hear your
thoughts and feedback if you want to
leave a comment below the video and stay
tuned for next episode
you